how long have the two of you been
writing partners barrington and I have
been writing together i would say we're
not a traditional writing partnership we
are co-writers on a particular
screenplay and so we've been doing that
now for three years three years yeah
yeah number of 2013 2013 yes happy
Anniversary thank you so it was about
yea it was about June was it yeah it was
about June when we when we connected so
it seems like the two of you are similar
but very different in certain styles of
writing do you think you could partner
up with someone that was just like you
that's a good question I don't know I've
had very few partnerships in my career
as i mentioned i'm a journalist by trade
and so usually I work by myself mostly
and this is actually my first feature
film screenplay so it's been an
interesting journey just kind of feeding
off of each other I think our
differences do help us it's opened me up
certainly to ideas and concepts in a
world that I may not have considered so
I think there is benefit especially for
what we're doing there is benefit in the
differences there is we're writing an
interracial inter-cultural cross faith
guy to love story and so our difference
is you know from where we both racially
where we come from adds to that it
really does you know we don't often
agree on everything you know we have
moments where it's like no no no this is
debate supposed to be and that's how
it's supposed to be but then you know
you back up and you think okay well this
is something valid and maybe I need to
consider it and so you know I take a you
know some time in like okay remember
that thing you were talking about let's
revisit that so so I think the
difference is to do add to
hopefully a deeper complexity of what
what we're trying to do yeah I don't
know I think for me I writing with
somebody who's just like like writing
with a clone has always been a dream
right because somebody can be somebody's
thinking exactly like your thinking and
but you can still be doing one thing
while work is happening and especially
if you're somebody who's kind of always
a little bit time poor in the various
resources I kind of never have time to
worry about the fact that I'm probably
money poor because I'm so time for that
but I'm always like oh where am I going
to put these hours so this idea of you
know putting something up there and
having somebody really understand what
you're where you're coming from is this
kind of fantasy but how well would it
work really I mean for something like
this it's like I know that we have a
Persian we have a Persian wedding scene
in our script Janice got in the car and
drove to San Diego and went to a persian
wedding show for an entire day and came
back at with tons of you know material
and vocabulary words and business cards
and my club neither me nor my clone
would drive to San Diego and go to the
to the Persian wedding show like we
would both be kind of introverted you
know people like like I am so in that
way like this has been super you know
it's very complimentary would it be the
best thing for every script maybe not
every script but but for this for this
script I think it works and you know and
that you know I talked about it a lot I
love the work that Barrington does do
and and I do enjoy the producing side of
things so it's like I whatever she wants
to to do producing I can produce it I
may not right with her but I believe in
the kind of work that she does the kinds
of characters that she puts out and so
if that was something that those are
ways that I would
love to try to work with her some more
but you know like my next script is
completely different with you know it's
a musical and its religious based and it
takes a different kind of a different
look in a different exploration that I
don't even think Barrington would have
an interest in so so interesting coming
to see it he'll be there and I'm already
interested in like seeing who maybe you
partner up with because I mean there's
got to be so many interesting people in
the world who are involved with with
that kind of thing yeah so I think with
any partnership it's it's always about
you know a marriage a writing
partnership anything it's about kind of
looking and seeing what you have and how
those pieces fit together and I feel
like we've we've managed to come up with
a pretty good jigsaw cut yeah or cuz cuz
we just had there was just a best
friends day or whatever it was and and
you know I have a lot of personal best
friends who I grew up with but then I
realized you know Barrington's my best
friend writing friend you know I don't
have a relationship with a relationship
with another writer in the way that I
have with Barrington I mean we've we've
had we've now traveled together a couple
of times we spend a lot of time together
here and you know she has keys to my
home and she comes in just like I'm home
so we're kind of you know you know a
good good little marriage as she was
saying so so she is someone who I whose
work I value whose opinions matter to me
and the relationship is important even
beyond the writing of it so so I think
that's what makes me really want to
continue to work with her in some kind
of way it may not be a writing kind of
way but definitely she stuck with me I
think one thing that's nice about a
partnership that works is when you
present an idea and you feel safe
telling the other person that I did even
if they don't like it so what works best
for the two of you is it the blunt you
know what sorry excuse my language this
sucks I don't like it
I know what could we see if it works
like this over here how does that work
between the two of you I think we're
doing that now you know there's some
there's some sticking points on some
things and we're just like you know
she's like okay I'm gonna leave you to
this I'll come back in a couple of days
and let's talk about it and so I I do
think that you know I'm a woman with
very strong opinions about a lot of
things and there are things that I feel
or into it in a way that maybe
barrington doesn't so then I take what
she's said and go okay I see where she's
coming from and I still don't agree or I
see where she's coming from and let's
see how this works and so it has been a
I think the thing that to back up I
think the thing that I've learned about
this partnership and and really try we
both want to try to make the best
product that we can and I think that's
the the core of it and so when she says
something and I'm like huh doesn't even
that doesn't make any sense to me but
then I have to I have to step back each
sometimes in the moment or sometimes
after and go you know what that thing
you were talking about it gave us some
consideration let's let's see how this
goes and see how this plays out and so
we're going through that now with a
particular scene where we're like hey
why is this scene like this why should
we do it like this I like it this way
she likes it this way and we're just
kind of trying to figure it out and and
I think the thing that wins is what we
both feel makes it the better story
right cuz oh go ahead sorry oh yeah I
think I guess you know to respond to
your question I think I think we're both
we always try to start with a place of
well I don't know how do you you know
how do you think this would work
and or you know what if it was this way
and then uh and then there's a but
there's also there's kind of a spectrum
of that you know there's the beginning
of a conversation and then there's like
ten o'clock at night we were just like
yeah no filters off yeah but um but
overall I mean I think I think we we do
have a pretty good rapport where we go
back and forth a little bit and and when
when it's sticky we take a little time
we come back together sometimes we Duke
it out and we haven't had like had to
resort to flipping coins yet so why
haven't i like the spectrum analogy
because it seems like with any great
partnership you have to be in a place
where you're not afraid of hurting one
others feelings but you don't do in a
way that really wounds someone I think
that's a real decision maker with a lot
of things yeah I trust I think the thing
that that it comes down to is that that
I trust barrington and I think that's
important I know she when she first came
on you know came on to help me with the
outline the one thing that I found
really revealing about Barrington was
that she took care of you know she was
thoughtful about what she wanted to do
and about the characters and and and
inquired and and wanted to know and so
it may you know like this may not have
been a project she was like oh yeah I'm
really going to co-write this with you
right now it was it started off as a I'm
a journalist who wrote a book she had
screenwriting experience and she was
going to help me develop an outline that
looked the way it was supposed to when I
presented it to a production company and
it was through that process where I
think for me it was really I think I can
work with this person are you interested
in working with a novice like me
so I think Trust was a big just was a
big deal for me and I felt like she was
somebody that I could open up to and be
comfortable knowing you know because she
now knows all my little ugly secrets and
the beautiful ones and the really wacky
ones and and I and I feel like I can
trust her with that part of me so I can
also trust her with this this is this
thing that that you know I kind of
conceived but we're birthing it together
you